هي المذنبه فهي من ذهبت الى هناك هذه
الفكره تعتبر الدليل براءه بالنسبه لمعجبي
مشهور متهم في قضيه اعتداء او اغتصاب على
الفضائل الالكترونيه تشكلت المحاكم
الافتراضيه وكل يدلي برايه ودفاعاته
والحديث هنا عن قضيه الفنان سعد المجرد
لكن البعض رفض تماما فكره الدفاع المجرد
حتى ان الناشطين وضعوا قائمه باستمناء
ابرز
المشاهير الذين اعلنوا عن تعاطفهم معه لمن
انتشرت عده نظريات للحاله النفسيه
للمدافعين عن المشاهير المتهمين
بالاعتداءات منهم انهم لا يستطيعون
التفريق بين الفن الذي يقدمه المشهور وبين
السلوكياته اخرون يحملون الضحيه المسؤوليه
كحاله فرديه في المجتمع ومع انتشار مثل
هذه القضايا بين مشاهير الفن والرياضه
والسياسه يرى مدافعون ان الضحايا اعضاء في
عصابات متخصصه في استدراج النجوم
والمشاهير لاتزازهم او تدمير مستقبلهم
الفني او الرياضي
بين الجدل الكبير الذي حصل بين مؤيد
ومعارض قضايا الاغتصاب في القانون الدولي
كيف يتم النظر فيها قانونيا طبعا نحن انون
يعني الاوانين ما فينا نقول بالقانون
الدولي فقط كل دوله الى قانون بطبيعه
الحال ولكن العامل الاساسي لهذه الجريمه
هو عامل الكونسنت عامل الرضا هل فينا نثبت
انه في رضا ولا لا هلا بنهايه الامر دخول
شخص معين على منزل شخص لا يعطي الرضا بشكل
تلقائي هل كانت ساعه متاخره طبعا لا يمكن
للاعتبار انه انا اعطيت رضا بشكل طلقات
اتفضل
عم بيقولوا انه الفتاه التي تعرضت لاغتصاب
كما ادعت من قبل سعد المجرد انه هي كانت
اصلا في غرفه الفندق يعني ما هي الخط
الفاصل او الحدود انه احنا نقول هذا
اغتصاب او هذا رضا طرفين صاروا مع بعض في
نفس الغرفه
لا يجوز لالنا نحن كمجتمع او كميديا او
كالسوشل ميديا انه نحكم على الضحيه او على
[موسيقى]
المعتدي او اللا جدلي طبعا بعد قبل ما
نثبت انه هو ضحيه او معتدله يعني في كتير
عالم متهم خلينا نقول متهم طبعا شكرا
للتوضيح القانونيستنا
بهذه الحاله هيدا شي خطر جدا ونحن كمحامين
منشوفها بجرائم اخف بكثير وقتها بتبلش
تنهي للاتهامات قبل ما يكون في حكم قضائي
مبرم
نهائي بعد الاحيان يعني بتؤدي للانتحار
وشفنا كثير حالات عالميا طبعا ادت
للانتحار سلبريتي صغيره بس لانه اتهم هذا
الشخص مش اكثر وكل الشتائم يلي نهايت عليه
بالسوشيال ميديا لذلك التوعيه بهذا الاطار
مهمه جدا لانه حياه الانسان مهمه ان كانت
الضحيه او المتهم ونحترم القانون ونحترم
القضاء ونخلي عنا حكم مبرم خيره النهار
يعني قبل ما نبلش نحن نعطي اتهامات ونكون
المحامي والقاضي والجنه التحقيق والشرطه
يعني محاكمه استمرت سبع سنوات مجرد لكونه
متهم شفنا قضايا ممثله كريستيانو رونالدو
نيمار اخرها اشرف حكيمي في فرنسا هل انه
القضيه طويله بسبب الجدل حولها لانه
المتهمه مشهور ام ان الدلائل صعبه في هكذا
وقائع
بالقانون نحن يعني لو كان القانون ابيض
واسود وسريع احنا خلينا نضب اغراضنا ونروح
على البيت نحن والاوضات ونخلي المكانات
تشتغل عنا مثل ما الماشينز عم تشتغل عن
غيرنا كل القضيه
ولازم ننبش على الدلائل ولازم ننبش على
الظروف يعني راح اعطي مثل اذا هيدا الشخص
كان له علاقات سابقه مع الشخص مع مع
الضحيه المتهم مع الضحيه وفي علاقات حميمه
الى ما هنالك على فترات سنوات الى ما
هنالك ممكن تكون دلائل انه هذا الشخص ولكن
مانا قاطعه يعني باي وقت انا اللي بدي
اقوله وهيدي توعيه كتير مهمه للنساء باي
وقت المراه ممكن ان ترفض هذه العلاقه حتى
لو اخر دقيقه قارت لا طبعا